[Music]
let's go to chrissy and alabama oh it's
sad in alabama today how are you chrissy
i'm doing well how are you good have you
all recovered
uh is this a sports reference
oh you're the best
you're the best it's literally a
national day of mourning in alabama last
night when we were recording this was
the alabama georgia game which georgia
demolished alabama and i love that you
don't even know what i'm talking about
christy
i mean chrissy talking about it
you're the best the best so good is this
a sports reference oh you're awesome all
right so what's up
all right um okay so my son um who's
about to be eight was just diagnosed
with a condition called pandas which
stands for oh the autopsy yeah
pediatric yeah pediatric autoimmune
neuro psychiatric disorder from stress
yeah tell me about that
um
it's horrible yeah
what does he have does he have ocd or
ticks or
like what
you've got
and ticks um it went from he was sick
with strep in
november um and
it almost felt like overnight after he
finished like his
you know five days of antibiotics
um he became my like sweet gentle
outdoor loving
great imagination little boy turned into
this
ocd
raging
um
almost manic yeah
defiance i mean i mean like it was like
looking at a stranger um
what a terrifying thing for your mom as
a mom yes terrifying and he i mean he
would go into these fits for hours like
just non-stop rage for hours yeah yeah
and we my you know my husband and i and
we have a four-year-old we were all just
like
what is happening
so what
how'd y'all go through the process to
get that diagnostic because i know it's
a it's a rare thing but you sometimes
people have to go through multiple
people to get diagnosed there
yes we were actually extremely lucky
because
um
the principal from my kid's school
said because he was struggling
at school and there everybody was like
he just seemed so different what's going
on and i said you know he hasn't really
been himself since he had stress
and the principal said have you ever
heard of pandas and i did end what
wow awesome so amazing and then she and
so i went into like
crazy research mode
and
and then we ended up finding out that
there was a
pediatrician
um in the town just down the way from us
um who
whose son had it and and he like is a
you know he he knows about it he knows
how to treat it
and he's actually opened up his own
practice um just dealing with more
complex cases because
the appointments need to be longer than
the 10-minute pediatrician appointment
exactly right yeah you work through it
and so we were super lucky because we've
been able to start treatment where
i have now joined some facebook groups
of like
for this and there are some people who
you know for years they didn't have an
official diagnosis geez and then did
they just
it's like uh low-dose steroids and and
antibiotics right
yep yes so we're on the steroids and the
antibiotic we're on our second month of
antibiotics in our first month of
steroids and
we're a day
four into the steroids and we've it's
already like we're seeing
chunks of our child come back to us so
awesome
good man that makes my heart feel good
i've heard and again i've got no no
direct experience with this at all
uh but i've heard that you can
it's like a light switch on and then it
i mean off and then it comes back on
that with yeah with the right um the
right lot of steroids and antibiotics
and what like obviously you have to be
working with a doctor to get into this
kind of stuff but that it can be magic
dark magic
into this thing and incredible magic on
the way out of this thing
yeah and then it's just doing a lot of
lifestyle changes of just
continuing to like vitamin d a lot of
these kids are real vitamin d low and
just so
um i think every kid is vitamin d low
these days but
unfortunately yeah one
high five to you i'm glad y'all figured
this out
big time shout out to your principal
who's just calling it out having a
doctor in your community that's so great
and you acted on it quick
um how can i help
um well i've heard you i listen to your
show all the time and i hear you talk
about nobody does feel so good yeah
i know i'm one of the 17.
um but like your your analogy with like
the 911 like rebuilding
um
after
because
he's coming back but like so much of our
life is
is just like a everything has changed
yes um
and you know he we have to be extremely
he's very immune compromised until we
can get him really healthy and well and
his gut healthy and his the inflammation
from his brain down so
we've ended up pulling him from school
because he just he can't risk getting
covet or flu or even just strep or cold
like anything will set him back because
his body is so
fragile right now can i just ask you one
quick question
you just mentioned gut health and is is
that in response to the antibiotics
um no so they're finding the connection
between like the gut minds
the gut brain connection i i just need
you to know that as as
that makes my heart feel so good
you are on the right path
the fact that you know even know about
that
puts you so in rare air and makes my
heart feel good the the antibiotics will
wreak havoc on the gut biome and having
a doctor who's working with you on
making sure that that stays healthy
oh my gosh your kid's gonna be great
chrissy's gonna be great god lee what a
that's a such a beautiful story okay i
interrupted you but yeah so he's
immunocompromised right he's got a lot
going on his br his yeah for those of
you listening
we could we could get off into the rails
on this thing but my understanding which
is limited is that strep is such an
ancient virus it is it's great at
mimicking it's great at hiding in the
body
and that it mimics other healthy cells
and at some point in rare cases the your
body will turn on
thinking that oh there it is it's hiding
and then it mows down a whole bunch of
good stuff
and
then all sudden your brain gets super
overinflamed and it just changes your
personality your response it just goes
haywire is that is that right yeah okay
yes yeah exactly okay um and so now and
then you know we have the added
uh
that uh i don't know what you would call
it but he's losing teeth now um and
every time that he a two starts to
wiggle that germs in his body and then
his body again attacks
that causing more inflammation so now
every time
so he literally had strep and then like
a week later he lost a tooth and then
like a week later he lost two so he gets
these what they call flare so all of a
sudden we'll be like
like we think we're doing really well
and then all of a sudden he's like
raging again and we're like what in the
world and then we like i'm like open
your mouth let me see and i'm like oh
wiggly too
but it's just going you know it's just
germs right up into the
blood brain barrier and all this stuff
so
um but yes it's basically so he you know
so the
you know we've had to pull him from
school
um
we actually just pulled his little
brother from school because you know if
he's at school with jeremy kids then you
know we just need to
do that and we're
is this is the doctor
is the doctor recommending this that you
pull the kids out
yeah well they were saying that um so
much of it some of the main some of the
symptoms which is so strange um is like
school refusal like just the
there's so much going on at school and
their brains just are so inflamed that
they can't
even handle like a stimulation from
school yeah okay so a lot of they can
develop like sensory issues and stuff
and kicks from that yep yep
all right so
i'm gonna give you good stuff and then
the hard stuff you ready
okay i'm ready so
if this is the first major
trauma with your kids
i'm assuming it is is that fair
um yes okay
um
you you're
looking to
this idea that our family is now
different
is incredible
chrissy i don't know
i
i don't know
what
where you come from
in there in alabama but you are
uh you are so far ahead of the curve
you're an inspiring woman it's awesome
your kids are so lucky to have you
understanding okay we're all different
now because we stared over the edge of
the cliff
and we realized oh gosh our kid could
just get a little bit of sickness and
then just be gone
and that most parents don't ever
experience that until it happens
it's terrifying everything's different
now
and
um then that turns into what about this
what about this and that's where you got
to be really careful and here's where i
want to
challenge you to not keep picking up the
flag pole and moving it inch by inch i
want you to pick it up and go
excavate the whole site
right the who we were is over we're new
now we're gonna build something new but
we're gonna we're gonna plant the flag
way over there and say this is who we're
gonna be here's what i'm talking about
it can be
your
determination to make sure your kid's
okay
can quickly turn into him being
terrified of his own body
yep because mom is always saying what
about this what about this and oh my
gosh what about that we gotta pull you
out of this we gotta take care of that
and if that's what the doctor's calling
for great
my one i love facebook groups because
they allow people who have strange
things like that most neighbor nope
nobody in your circle has
kids with this right
so
you get instant community
and also
you get all of the one in a trillion
things
and it turns you into a paranoid maniac
right
are you there yet
um no i'm i am self-aware enough to know
like uh so i've started to like i've
started to eat like when it first
started happening
like in december we were just kind of
like what is happening and i did a lot
you know i did my research and now
i'm starting to step back more and being
like
i have
the plan you know and so i've started to
like you know i'm reading books before
bed instead of like i'm implementing
good
boundaries of things and just being like
turn it off
every and every case is different so if
i'm reading that this one person had a
13 year struggle with this that's not
going to help me right now yeah yes yes
chrissy you continue to amaze me yes
turn it all off you've got the info you
need you got a great doctor
let's be done with to inputting new
information there's not going to be a an
article on google you stumble onto and
you go oh i'll try this it's just gonna
be another
facebook
person being like oh yeah well i found
it in the vacuum and you're gonna be
like oh okay let's burn the vacuum it's
it's never gonna stop right it's 5g it's
because of the oh my gosh what whatever
it is pretty much and yeah
absolutely take it off so you're there a
key to when you when you decide we're
going to excavate and build something
new
key number one is having somebody do it
with you is your husband in with you
good guy yes oh yeah okay well he won
the lottery marrying you and hopefully
it's reciprocal hopefully you won the
lottery marrying him
y'all decide we're going to take care of
our marriage
and our bodies you have to do that
when a kid gets sick
the first thing that goes out the window
is intimacy
the second thing that goes out the
window is
treating each other with kindness
the third thing that goes out is our
budget the fourth just these stable
um
intentional ways of doing life go out
the door because everything's on fire
yep and now you said it and i'm gonna
use your own words it's not on fire
anymore now you can just read books
before bed
is that you know what you hear i'm going
now you can start redoing life again
and you're going to feel guilty for
doing life that that's going to be the
key here and then deciding what do we
want this thing to look like so we got a
kid who's got a rare thing we're gonna
keep trusting the doctors on this
and we're gonna keep doing the right
things there and we're gonna watch a
movie because movies are fun
and we are going to oh we can't play
basketball anymore cool we're going to
get a foosball table we're going to
deliver to the house we're going to play
foosball because that's going to be fun
we're going to we're going to find joy
in whatever
context whatever ecosystem makes sense
for joy for us but we're not going to
live a joyful life
yeah and we're going to grieve the
absolute hell out of this thing because
it sucks
yeah right
have you done that yet have you had a
moment where you're just by yourself and
you or with the girlfriend and you just
broke the crap down
yeah um i was super lucky that my mom
was able to fly
uh we're military so we're down here
without family and stuff and my mom when
it was first happening i was like
something is happening mom and like you
need to come down here
um and
we her and i were able to kind of get
away and just um
i don't know i just cried and she's just
i was able to just vent and cry and be
mad good good good
and just like
scream my husband and i even thought
maybe we could invest in a um like a
punching bag we can maybe have in the
garage
so i would invest that's fine i have one
in my garage i would invest in
a
uh journal and i know that's so lame i
would write this stuff down so that you
have the story to tell your son in five
years and 10 years in 20 years
and that you're going to tell his future
spouse someday you're going to write
this down and you're going to tell the
story
um and make sure that all the feelings
all of the the ups and the downs today
was a great day today was an awful day i
cried all day i'm so sorry that you're
going through this i hate you're not in
school i want him to see that stuff and
i want that crap out of your body onto
the paper yeah
and we've been talking i mean he can
tell when it when he's like he has said
like something is wrong with me there's
something in my brain like he's aware
that these changes are happening he when
he goes under the rages he doesn't
remember them
um which i guess is a blessing because
of some of the horrific things he's
he has said
when it first happened
i mean we remember yeah well and again
you're gonna have to work really hard
and when i say work really hard you're
gonna have to be honest with your
husband he's got to be honest with you
you're gonna have to write stuff down
and get a counselor if you need one but
you're gonna have to know he was eight
and he's he's having a brain disorder
right now
but when he says i hate you or you fill
in the blank
that's not personal even though god it
feels personal it's like it's like
poltergeist right
yeah and my uh father
was bipolar and committed well he died
from suicide
when i was 18 and we are i'm seeing that
a lot of this is triggering yes
um yes i will have to go back to emdr
eventually so your body's got a trauma
response but it here's the thing yeah
you
that even makes more sense but i know
it's different but i know it's different
it's different but our bodies
they'll say oh we remember when we were
out of control uh-huh we remember the
terror we remember the fear we've got a
system for this to run the program
and you've also done a lot of work to
heal from your dad's passing
and
those same skills will come into play
here as you practice a new life
but yeah if you've been down that road
before and you know yourself think yeah
go call a trauma counselor do it today
call somebody and just say i need to
just go vomit up here
i've been through trauma before i've
been through it hard i thought i was
gonna i lost my dad i thought i was
about to lose my son
or i thought
he was gonna be with us and be gone and
i would have lost him in in spirit but
not in body oh that is so terrifying so
terrifying yes go talk to somebody
and if you need to get punched back get
a punching bag but also get a journal
and write these things down to keep
these things as a story be super honest
and open get a group get people to
that you can have in your life
just to go
yeah
and get off the internets i'm so proud
of you god i'm so proud of you you're
amazing chrissy you're amazing
man
in fact you want to gut biomass and you
decided to self get off of the internet
so great
find ways go on a date with your husband
go on a date
get a babysitter and go on a date figure
out how to do that
or it may be that put a kit a video on
for the kids in one room and you'll go
close the door and you'll have a date
like make sure y'all are staying plugged
in with each other that calms your brain
down
you let your brain know
i wasn't safe but now i am now i'm okay
so proud of you give me a call let me
know how he's doing i really want to
know cause i'm gonna guess he's gonna be
up and running around in the next month
or two and i want to
hear that story and we'll tell everybody
who's listening thank you so so much for
your call chrissy